the entire time I knew him he only ever  had one call  to wipe out half the universe if he gets  all the Infinity stones she can do it  with the snap of his fingers just like  that tell me his name again  Santos  [Music]  we got one advantage  she's coming to us  we have a dance once so that's what we  use  [Music]  let's talk about this plan ears I think  it's good except it sucks so let me do  the plan and that way it might be really  good Wow  [Music]  in is near  and um  half of humanity will still exist  perfectly balanced  as all things should be  I hope that remember you  [Music]  I'm Peter by the way dr. strange Oh  using your made-up names then I am  spider-man  [Music]